today we're going to be going out with  two investors a guy called neck who is  coming with some friends and then come  all the way from Greece to the US  tonight and there's also a guy called  Felix joining us this would be great dad  I always learn a lot how to download  most  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  we just have we've had a blast I think  this is a great day and it's definitely  worth wild my trip from Brighton and  also in basis trip from Greece so we're  very placement they if you would like to  get in touch with me gates at you want  the team and we've happy to do what we  can and help you insist you in your  journey it's becoming financially free  free props  [Music]  [Music]